un français sur dix est malade de
l'alcool et chaque jour cinq personnes
meurent d'un accident lié à l'alcoolisme
des statistiques qui font froid dans le
dos publiée dans un rapport qui vient
d'être remis aux gouvernements son
auteur un journaliste hervé chabalier
qui a lui même souffert des ravages de
l'alcool
ils demandent que la lutte contre
l'alcoolisme devienne une priorité
nationale
dominique dumas guys and dolls l'alcool
tue 23000 personnes chaque année dans
notre pays
5 millions une consommation abusive en
dépit des différentes campagnes depuis
une vingtaine d'années sur les écrans
les problèmes demeurent notamment chez
les plus jeunes le rapport remis ce
matin au ministère de la santé souligne
les points les plus sensibles en
proposant plusieurs mesures concrètes
notamment pour la prévention
faut que ces généralistes pas
suffisamment formés pour arriver à
détecter derrière un symptôme ou une
demande
le vrai problème qui est celui de
l'alcool et non seulement il faut des
médecins mais en plus le ministre a
parlé tout à l'heure c'est une
proposition on a fait des conseillers en
alcoologie aires des gens qui sont pas
des médecins pas du tout mais sur des
gens ils sont formés pour ça qu'ils vont
être le mot est pas joli et sorte de
dénicheur d'alcoolisme et qui vont aller
dans l'iss dans les hôpitaux dans les
centres sociaux dans les centres
médicaux voir derrière les consultations
qu'elle est si le problème de l'alcool
est là ce rapport est l'objet d'un débat
public afin de déterminer les axes pour
lutter plus efficacement contre
l'alcoolisme
moi ce que je veux c'est que nous
fassions durablement évoluer les
comportements
parce que cette lutte contre
l'alcoolisme est un véritable enjeu une
priorité de santé publique dans un pays
où la tradition et le terroir font
partie aussi d'un art de vivre le
changement des mentalités est un nouveau
défi pour que l'alcool ne soit plus un
problème tabou